Speaker 1: Let's start today with some of Joe
Biden's recent accomplishments. You know, on the
bonus show today, we'll be talking about President
Joe Biden's first presidential veto that was
ordered. I'm not going to do that now because we
have a plan to talk about it a little bit later.
But as the former president seems to be closer and
closer to a criminal indictment, it's important
not to lose sight of the fact that without
controversy, without drama, without drawing
with a Sharpie on a hurricane map or asking about
nuking Europe or a hurricane or whatever the case
may be, Joe Biden has accomplished a bunch of
little things, none of which individually are
completely mind blowing. But it's a lot of little
very important things. Let me know if you find
this interesting. Let me know if you find this
informative. Here are some examples. The FCC
is going to release some additional funds this
week to support what's called the Affordable
Connectivity Program. And this is a program it's
part of the bipartisan infrastructure law that
was passed under Joe Biden. And it will provide
households that are eligible with a $30 credit
towards the cost of their Internet service plan
or a $75 monthly credit for households living on
tribal land towards their Internet service. And
so the idea here is get more people broadband.
The effect, you might say, well, how many people
will that help? It'll help a bunch of people and
then it will. It's expected to get broadband to
16 million households that don't currently have
it. That's like 5% of the United States. That's
a really big deal. Not exploited. It's not a
new health care plan, but it is a program with a
measurable benefit that will get something that
is increasingly a requirement. How do you
increasingly how do you exist in the world
and and avail yourself of all of the normal
amenities that many of us take for granted?
If you don't have broadband Internet? Well, this
will get 6 million households. Broadband Internet,
that's a great thing. The Department of Health and
Human Services, HHS, is releasing half a billion
dollars in low income home energy assistance
funds. And the idea here is help people cover home
heating costs. We've had inflation. Energy prices
are high. The Biden administration in November
announced the distribution of a bunch of this
money and it is now happening and it's getting
a little bit of a bump to help people pay for
heating. This is a great thing. Again, it doesn't
solve the problem that groceries are expensive.
It doesn't deal with stagnant wages. But now we've
got credits towards broadband and funds for home
heating. That's a really great thing. Then we go
to prescription drugs. There are new details
on which Medicare Part B drugs. Now, remember,
if you get access to the bonus show we recently
talked about, what are these drugs? Medicare
Part B drugs are expensive drugs administered
by doctors. If the prices of certain drugs go
up faster than inflation, there are going to be
funds to subsidize the cost of those drugs back
down. Does this fix the problem of health care
prices or prescription drug costs? No, but it's
going to identify drugs that will be qualified
for inflation rebates or excessive price increases
when the price of these drugs goes up above and
beyond the cost of inflation. And so people who
benefit from these funds will see the prices
of these drugs to them lowered in some cases
significantly. That's another really great thing.
Now we go to the EPA, where this it's really broad
spectrum stuff. We go to the EPA. The EPA has
taken a step forward in delivering clean water,
particularly to disadvantaged communities, by
proposing some new standards, national standards
for drinking water, contamination levels and what
what amounts of certain elements are allowed to
be there in terms of PFOA s substances. This is
expected to prevent thousands of deaths and reduce
by tens of thousands the number of illnesses
attributable to those types of water contaminants.
Is it perfect? No. Does it fix everybody's water
everywhere? No, it certainly doesn't. But is it
a good thing with a measurable impact? Yes,
it is. And then a couple other small things.
A Department of Transportation is launching its
community electric vehicle charging program. Oh,
but not everybody can afford electric vehicles.
Right. But as we go towards affordability,
hopefully one of the big impediments is having
infrastructure to charge your car where you live
and or. Work. And the Department of Transportation
is launching that. That's a program that was
previously put in place, but it is now launching.
And then the Department of Energy is moving
forward with $750 million for clean hydrogen
research. Now, I know there are people who say,
David, hydrogen fuel is not the future. Well, it
might be. It might not be the future for vehicles,
but maybe it is elsewhere. It's certainly
something that should be researched and that
money is now being made available. These are all
modest changes that will have measurable, positive
impacts for in some cases, thousands or tens of
thousands or with some of these bigger programs,
even millions of people quietly accomplishing
things. Couple different thoughts. Number one,
is this interesting to people? Is it interesting
to hear about some of these things that are
happening? Number two, is there a disconnect
between those who benefit from these programs
and making the connection that, oh, this is
because either of the Inflation Reduction Act
or because of other programs? I like that
maybe I am more satisfied with Joe Biden's
job performance than I thought. And what I
mean by that is very often people are asked,
do you approve or not of the job that the
president is doing? And oftentimes people say,
I do or I don't. And very often it's driven by
what's in the news. Oh, the Afghanistan withdrawal
went well or it didn't go well. I approve or
disapprove when you would think if people were
more aware of some of these programs, if you're
now getting 30 bucks a month towards broadband and
they're starting to build charging stations near
where you live and you're getting a home heating
assistance and a medicare Part B drug is now
being subsidized for you. That's tangible stuff,
but only if you know about it. Might it influence
your level of satisfaction with the job that
Joe Biden is doing. So that's another
aspect to this. Let me know your thoughts.
Do you want to regularly hear these sorts of
updates? Curious to hear what people think